let's be honest this week Sean Hannity
one and the rest of America lost the pro
Trump media led by Hannity has circled
the wagons around President Trump
they've distracted people about the
truth involving Trump's Russia ties and
they've done everything possible to
destroy faith in Robert mullahs probe
and look Hannity won at work you gotta
give him credit where it's due
Hannity gave a megaphone to the GOP
congressmen who said they had a smoking
gun memo proving a deep state conspiracy
against Trump
Hannity hyped it night after night after
night in January like a human countdown
clock we have massive breaking news
tonight the biggest frankly we have ever
reported on about the Russia
investigation and they will make
Watergate look like an insignificant
blimp on your radar a source is telling
me this is going to all be proven right
I have a message tonight for the special
counsel robert muller your witch hunt is
now over it is the biggest national
scandal by far in our lifetime what we
are in covering uncovering here is far
worse than Watergate people need to be
held accountable
Trump reportedly watched that and loved
it and he told aides the memo needed to
come out because it would undermine
Muller and on Friday we all saw the
coverage it was never gonna live up to
the hype when you've got Hannity talking
about this being Watergate times a
thousand but the noise around the memo
doesn't make much sense anyway
Devon Nunez alleges surveillance abuses
even though he recently voted to support
greater surveillance powers and the
timeline doesn't make much sense either
but come on when you're trying to
confuse people that doesn't matter all
the questions all the headlines all the
doubt all the curiosity all the concern
that was the point to get it on the
front page to sow doubt in division that
was the point and look at cable news the
nation's deep divide was visible in
prime time there is new vital
information that is even more damning
more damaging than any
we've told you so far this is Watergate
times a thousand that's it that's all
they've got Nunez hinted that there's
more to come that this is just the tip
of the iceberg you know what the only
thing better than one WAC memo more wack
memos there it is that's a preview of
what's coming next GOP congressmen are
promising more memos more revelations
and Fox is already telling people to
stay tuned meanwhile MSNBC is already
making fun of it but you know the memo
this entire memo thing I know it's
confusing but it gives the Hannity's of
the world an alternative reality to live
in it gives Trump a way to say he's
vindicated even though he's not it lets
Trump allies say Muller's probe is
tainted and needs to be shut down it
allows them to turn every claim around
on its head collusion yeah there was
collusion by the Democrats obstruction
yeah the Dems obstructed it's it's like
that old childhood schoolyard taunt I'm
rubber you're glue whatever you say
bounces off of me and sticks to you now
the current in vogue talking point is
there is an important investigation
going on but it's not the investigation
into Russian interference in the
election it's the investigation into the
FBI that's the alternative reality and
look this campaign of confusion is good
for anity his ratings are way up it's
good for Trump as well but it's bad for
the country